[Music]
okay what just happened well let's back
up this is China and right now there's a
trend happening in China where people on
the Abdo ying are recording themselves
transforming normally the trend features
a cryptex remix of the songs goochy
goochy by Kreayshawn and i got by beats
antique legally we can't play those
songs but that's okay we'll make this
work but on top of everything there's
the all-important soundbite from
Riverdale Karma's a [ __ ] now people all
over the world are trying to Karma's a
[ __ ] mean so we thought we tried for
ourselves so I didn't know much about
this Karma's a [ __ ] mean my friend
actually sent me a youtube compilation
of the meme on Facebook in the next day
I saw in a BuzzFeed and I watch the
video wow it's so [ __ ] cute and
wholesome and so simple and
straightforward it's literally just like
here's me one way here's me another way
I love a good reveal who doesn't love a
good reveal this is why magicians and
like drag queens are famous we don't in
America or like in Western world usually
see that many memes from China so I
think it's been really fun to see you
know like Chinese go around I'm so glad
that there's room for just pure internet
joy in 2018 I'm so excited to make it
come as a [ __ ] video it's going down
I'm ready I think
Oh
[Music]
oh well Karma's a [ __ ]
oh wow
[Music]
it was so hard it's hard being cool that
was interesting that was really fun I'm
not gonna lie it was my dream to come
with Honda you just kind of believe in
yourself that you're late hell yeah I'm
[ __ ] cool
it boosts your confidence in the little
bit of time that it takes to do so go
ahead and do it man you'll be surprised
[Music]